When I started the project,...
...I started thinking about how we could actually automate the process.
There are a variety of ways you can automate.
You could buy a very, very expensive kit off the shelf,...
...but Legos seemed like the simplest way.
The great thing about the robots is that once you tell them what to do,...
...they can just do it very precisely over and over again.
So a day later, I can come back and see a fully made sample.
Research is a funny thing...
...because you might think that we order everything up out of scientific catalogs,...
...but actually, a lot of the things that we use around the lab are household items,...
...things we've picked up at the local home goods store.
And so, our robots just fit in with that mindset.
The importance in its science is the creativity and going forward,...
...it's not exactly what tools you used to get there.